It's, my massive pleasure to,
introduce Michael Bronstein.
Michael Bronstein
is a professor
at Imperial College
London where
he holds the chair in machine
learning and pattern
recognition,
and also head of
graph learning
research at Twitter.
He also leads, the,
machine learning project, in,
project SETI, a TED audacious
prize winning collaboration
aimed at understanding
the communication
of, sperm whales.
So without further ado,
over over to you,
Michael. Welcome.
Thank you, James.
I hope you can see
and hear me well.
So thanks a lot,
for the invitation to to join
this presentation today.
And I would like
to talk about,
deep learning graphs and,
try to outline
what it is about,
what is the present state of
this science and
technology and
what the future
columns for it.
So allow me to
start with actually
a little bit far
away and taking
a step back and talking about
the concept of
inductive bias.
So this is
a fundamental notion
in learning and it refers to
the the set of
assumptions that,
a machine learning system has
to do about, the data
in the problem
at hand. And let's take a very
simple machine
learning system,
some of the earliest neural
networks called,
multilayer perceptrons.
We know that they
can approximate
any continuous function to any
desired accuracy.
We call this
property universal
approximation,
and it was proven
in the end of the eighties for
for these architectures.
And, it sounds
like a good piece
of news. Right?
Because we can
represent anything
we want with multilayer
perceptrons.
But with the moment we try to
apply these simple
neural networks
to real problems dealing with
high dimensional data,
they tend to fail miserably.
And, let's look for example at
the problem of digit
classification,
one of the simplest
examples of
a computer vision problem.
Essentially, what
we want to say
here is whether what we see is
the digit three.
And the way that you can think
of this problem
when you try to
apply multilayer perceptron to
this digit classification,
you just stack the image into
a vector and pass
it as the input
to the, to this
neural network.
The problem is
that what happens
when we have another instance
of the same image
where the unit
is just shifted
by one pixel as
you can see here.
And the input to the neural
network can be very different
because the neural network is
absolutely unaware
about the structure
of the image and thinks of it
as a one dimensional vector.
So it will take
a lot of examples
and very complex architecture
with a lot of parameters to
learn in variance
to shifts from
the data. And this is one of
the reasons why early attempts
to apply neural networks to,
to image data, to
computer vision
problems, failed,
failed miserably.
Now the breaks
will in applying
neural networks to images has
come from the right
inductive bias.
And these are convolutional
neural networks
from the seminal
work of Jan de Kann,
where the inductive
bias is what
we call a translation
equivariance.
Basically, it's hardwired into
the neural
network architecture
in the form of shared
local weights.
And this way, we have now way
less parameters and this idea
that you can recycle the same
weights and apply them at
different positions
at the image
at different scales
is very powerful.
That was really
what made these
architectures so successful,
and the results speak
for themselves.
As you know, CNNs have really
revolutionized the field of
computer vision in
the past decade.
Now let me show you
a different problem.
What you see here
is a a molecule,
and, this is a molecule
of caffeine.
I hope that in
the break you've
had enough of it.
So I have a little
bit in my my
tea cup here. And,
we can model it as a graph.
The nodes here
represent the atoms
and the agents
represent the chemical
bonds. Let's say that we want
to predict some
chemical property
of this molecule,
for example,
what physicists or chemists
would call
the atomization energy.
So it's the energy that takes
to break this molecule apart.
And, this is
really fundamental
problem in, drug
design and drug
drug discovery
to be able to do
virtual screening to predict
certain properties of,
potential drug candidates.
So how do we represent
this molecule?
Again, we can just
take the features
of the nodes and put them into
a vector as we did
before with an image.
The problem though
that we have many,
many more ways to do it.
Actually, any permutation
of the nodes,
produces a valid
representation vector.
And the kind of invariance we
want to have here is different
from the previous example.
Here, we need to
account for all
the possible permutations.
And molecules are
just one example
of graph structured data.
In fact, we see
graphs everywhere.
Probably the most prominent
example are social networks
where the nodes are users and
the edges represent
their social
relations and interactions.
So you can think
of Facebook or
Twitter or any
other graph that
is generated by
by the activity
of of humans.
We also encounter graphs,
or networks in
biological sciences
where we look at
the interactions
between different biomolecules
such as proteins and
drugs and so on.
In computer graphics
and computer
vision where we
use graphs with
maybe a bit more
structure that
are called meshes to represent
three d objects and, in many,
many other fields
like in brain
imaging where
graphs can be used
to represent
functional networks
and so on.
So if you want
the gist of what
deep learning on graphs is,
it's essentially
finding the right
inductive bias for
graph structured
data, which is sometimes also
called relational
inductive bias.
And in two thousand sixteen,
I wrote a position paper with
Jan de Kann, Pierre
van der Geist,
Joanne Brunner,
and Arthur Schlam,
where we connected several
attempts to deal with,
irregular or non Euclidean
structures in deep learning,
which we named,
geometric deep learning.
So I would say
that now I would
probably write it
completely different.
So I think there
is a much more
depth to this
idea of trying to
geometrize machine
learning problems.
But somehow this term is now
used synonymously with graph
deep learning or
graph representation
learning. And, as I said,
there is more to that.
We can think of geometrical
learning as a framework
unifying grids,
graphs, curves, and gauges,
which is high energy physics
term for manifolds.
So, in fact, we
like calling it
the four g of deep learning.
So this year, graph neural
networks have
officially become
one of the hottest topics in
machine learning.
And at least judging
from the submissions
of the six of ICLR,
one of the main
conferences in ML,
this has been one
of the popular
keywords. So let me show you
some more details
and let's look
at classical CNNs.
So if you look at
classical CNNs
that take as input an image,
which we define as a function
that I denote here,
by x on a regular two
dimensional grid,
What convolution
does is a form
of weighted aggregation
of the values
in the pixels of
a neighborhood.
And we can do
the same thing in
the graph. The neighbors will
be the nodes that are attached
by edges to any
node in the graph.
So so far, it looks
all the same.
But one thing to
notice is that
when we move to
a different location,
we still have
a constant number
of neighbors because the grid
is regular. So in this case,
each pixel is
connected to four
neighbors. And on the graph,
on the other hand,
we might have a very different
number of neighbors.
We had six neighbors
in the previous
node and five
neighbors, here.
And if you think of
social networks,
these differences
can be huge.
So a popular user like Donald
Trump has millions
of followers
and other users
might have just
a few tens or hundreds.
And this is what
is called the node
degree in graph,
in graph theory.
Another thing to
observe is that
on agreed, we have a fixed
ordering of the neighbors.
We can always talk about,
a node to the left
or a node to
the right, and this allows me
to always apply
the same weights
to the first
neighbor and other
to the second and so on.
And this is exactly
the idea of
weight sharing
in conversion on
your networks that that I
mentioned in the beginning.
So if you represent
this as a matrix,
we actually see that there is
a special structure
that is called,
circulant matrix.
And, because circulant
matrices commute,
we also have
commutativity with
the shift operator,
which is called
shift equivariance.
And in fact, you can actually
derive convolution from first
principles of symmetry,
of translation symmetry.
And, this is the the idea of
geometric deep learning where
inductive biases emerge from,
first geometric principles.
So on the graph,
the situation is
rather different.
The ordering of the neighbors
is completely arbitrary,
so we don't have
a canonical way
of assigning a fixed weight to
a given node.
And this actually
makes graph neural networks
quite different
from traditional
CNNs in the form
of the variance
that that we get.
So here's a blueprint for how
to do conversion
like operations
on graphs, which
have two types
of operations.
We can aggregate
information from neighbors,
and we can process it in some
way and then update
the features
of an old. So
these are the two
operations, aggregate
and update.
And aggregate has
a most general
form of a function
that is applied
to to the neighbor
node features.
And importantly,
this, function is,
prohibition environment.
And there are some important
particular examples
of architectures
where this can be
linear aggregation
or an aggregation
that uses some
form of attention mechanism.
So let's now dive more into
the details of what is similar
and what is different,
between graph neural networks
and traditional deep learning
pipelines and look at CNNs.
So if we look at historical
developments of CNNs that that
that appeared in
computer vision
problems. So early models such
as AlexNet from two thousand
twelve were
relatively shallow,
and they have
just eight layers
with relatively large filters
of up to eleven by
eleven pixels.
And, as CNNs became
more commonplace
in computer vision,
they also became
deeper and used
smaller filters.
So the VGG architecture had
twenty layers and
three by three
filters. And there are several
reasons for, why
this happened.
First of all, obviously,
smaller filters
are more efficient
computationally. But
more importantly,
it was shown that
in convolutional
neural networks,
you can construct
complex features
from simple ones,
the property that we call
compositionality.
So if you look
at the features that that that
are noted in different layers
in the neural network,
you see that the first layers
have primitive
geometric features
such as edges or corners.
And as you go deeper,
you get more complex,
complex features.
It appears not to be the case
in graph neural networks and
it's really wishful thinking,
composing complex structures
from simple ones.
For example, it
was shown recently
that graph neural networks of
the message passing type are
equivalent to what is called
the Weiszler Lemann graph
isomorphism test,
which is a classical algorithm
from graph theory
that determines
if two graphs are
isomorphic by
means of some color refinement
procedure. And,
this is a test
that can tell you
whether two graphs
are possibly
isomorphic, but it's necessary
but insufficient condition.
In this case, for example,
the the the test
will fail, because,
it is known that
it cannot count,
simple substructure
such as triangles.
And one of these
graphs has triangles,
another one doesn't.
So there exists higher order,
more powerful
versions of the the
Weisler Lemann test,
but they have,
prohibitive computational and
memory complexity.
So another thing
to notice that
unlike in the traditional
architectures,
it is actually difficult to to
train deep, craft
neural network
architectures and,
they require a lot of,
tricks such as
regularization and,
architectural, changes such as
residual connections.
And, the bottom line that that
even with these tricks,
sometimes shallow,
baselines work
better than than
the deep super duper graph
architectures.
So one reason for
this is what is called feature
oversmooling. It means that
features on the nodes tend to
collapse to a single point in
the feature space.
But probably
a more fundamental
phenomenon is that,
it was described in
the recent paper,
by Uri Alon that,
there is a bottleneck.
So in some graphs,
where the number of neighbors
tends to grow exponentially as
you expand
the neighborhood size,
you get a lot of neighbors,
whose features you
need to squeeze
through a single
feature vector.
And if you have,
this exponential growth of
neighbors and you also happen
to depend on long
range information,
you run into the bottleneck
phenomenon.
And, in a sense,
it's not clear
for which cases,
for which problems,
and for which graphs,
that helps.
So in a sense,
deep graph neural networks try
to use many layers
with small filters,
just one hot filters.
The alternative
is to use fewer
layers but make
the filters bigger,
and that's exactly what we try
to do in the work with my
collaborators at Peter.
We took this idea
to the extreme.
We wanted to see
what we can do
with a convolutional layer,
just single
paragraph convolutional
layer. And, an analogy in
classical CNNs
would be to have
a shallow network
with bigger filters.
The nice thing here is that if
we use linear diffusion,
linear message passing,
we can pre compute the diffuse
features and then
it boils down
to just applying
simple multilayer
perceptrons to the predefined
old features.
And as a result,
the neural network
is extremely
efficient, and it scales to to
very large graphs.
So the surprising finding is
that such
a simple architecture
performs almost
on par with some
of the much more complex state
of the art deeper models.
And again,
this brings the question when
do you need depth
for what kind
of graphs and for what
kind of problems.
What is for sure that it's
significantly faster by more
than an order of magnitude in
training and inference, and,
it resembles the the inception
convolutional neural networks
that that were pioneered by
Google a few years
ago because,
we use filters of
different size,
as was used in that in that
architecture. So
there are certain
graph quantities
we cannot compute
by means of message passing no
matter how deep
we make our own
neural network.
And I should say that this is
not fully understood and on
the contrary,
there are examples
of properties such
as graph moments,
for example, that can only be
computed unless
the network has
certain minimal depth.
So it's still
an open theoretical
question. So what
we can do is,
to help graph neural networks
to count substructures by
providing these counts as some
peak computed
feature vectors.
It's kind of positional or
structural encoding,
and we can do this by,
peak counting some
structures of size k.
This could be, for example,
triangles or clicks or cycles
or paths of
different lengths.
And we provide this as node or
edge fishes and
then do standard
message passing.
So we call this architecture
graph subtraction networks.
And, the nice thing about it
that it actually
retains the linear
complexity and
the local structure
of standard message passing
neural networks.
And, the,
comp the the precomputation is
the part that might
be expensive.
In the worst case,
it is as complex as the high
order of Le Mans, methods.
But, in practice,
it can the complexity
is much lower.
So what we gain in
this way is that,
the graph's
abstraction network
is strictly more powerful than
the the device for a lemon or
the equivalent message passing
graph neural networks.
And we have problem specific
inductive bias, we see that,
for example,
by by counting
certain structures
such as clicks in
social network graphs,
we get significantly
better performance.
And especially interesting for
molecular datasets describe
chemical compounds.
Cycles are important
motif, and,
they're abundant in organic
molecules with structures such
as aromatic rings.
And, again, this
is my favorite
molecule of caffeine.
It has two rings of
size five and six.
So if you use
a graph substructure
networks with
these structures,
we get significant gain in
performance of
predicting chemical
properties of
molecular graphs.
And the experiment shown here
is on the TING dataset that is
often used for
virtual screening
of drug like compounds.
And I believe
that applications
of graph deep learning in
computational
chemistry and drug
design and discovery
are probably
the most promising.
Allow me to come back to this
point in a few minutes.
So in the remaining time,
let me share some thoughts on
what I believe to be,
the next steps in this field.
And, I would like
maybe to make
here a small confession.
I'm somewhat
disappointed with,
the the when I
started working on,
genetic deep learning probably
around six years now,
I was expecting
something similar
to the revolution
that happened
with the adoption
of deep learning
in computer vision and we have
not seen anything
similar yet.
And, of course,
there is a lot of progress and
even some, commercial
applications of,
craft neural networks
in the industry.
Well, I could here shamefully
put the success of a startup
company that I founded
with my students,
that where we were using graph
neural networks to detect
misinformation on
on Twitter and
were acquired by
Twitter last year.
Yet, I think it has been more
of an evolution even
though a fast one.
And, let me try to explain and
maybe highlight
some points that
are important for
future progress
in this field that that will
make maybe a broader adoption
of deep learning on graphs.
So there are three
things really
that sort of made deep
learning happen,
and these are data compute and
and software. So in case of
computer vision,
data was a benchmark
such as ImageNet.
Compute was
the computing power
of graphics hardware,
the GPUs,
and software was open source
tools such as PyTorch
or TensorFlow
that that have
democratized deep
learning. Now if you look at
the situation,
in graphs, well,
we also see emergence of
standardized
benchmarks such as
ImageNet for graphs,
the open graph benchmark,
software libraries such as DGL
or PyTorch Geometric that
implements some
state of the art
graph learning architectures.
There are problems
of efficiency
and scalability.
So this is really what has
precluded so far
the application
of graph learning
to industrial
scale and industrial
settings.
So now we have,
several methods that that can
really work in
production systems
of large scale.
If we look at,
problems such as
Twitter and Facebook,
they deal with
dynamic graphs.
So the graph is not
a static session,
but it's living and
evolving in time.
Nodes are added and deleted,
and it's really,
better to think of this graph
as a kind of
a synchronous stream
of events that form it,
like edge and node insertions
and deletions. And there are
currently just
few architectures
that support these cases.
So this is one of
the topics that,
I'm working, on a Twitter work
with or we've
developed recently
what we call temporal
graph networks.
It's an architecture that
generalizes message passing
neural networks to
dynamic graphs.
Now talking about high
order structures,
I already mentioned them in
the context of
our work on graph
substructure networks.
And I would like
to stress again
that so far, graph
neural networks
were primarily
focused on simple,
structures such as nodes and
edges and message passing on
these structures.
But we all live
in many complex
networks such as biological or
social networks.
We have complex high order
structures and motifs, and,
we want to better
exploit them.
So I believe that
there will be,
in the future
emergence of methods
that take advantage of these
more complex structures and
their interesting relations to
previous works that have been
done on topological
data analysis
such as persistent
homologies on graphs.
Another important topic is
actually the very assumption
that we are given
an input graph
to start with. In many cases,
this is not the case.
We don't have the graph.
We just have some
cloud of points
and the graph can be
just a convenience
that can be used to
model the underlying
data structure.
We did first work
that we called
dynamic graph CNNs.
It were we showed that it's
possible to design
graph neural
networks that build the graph
as part of
the learning process
on the fly.
And, the graph, for example,
can be constructed,
as k nearest
neighbor graph and
updated between the layers,
in a way that is optimal for
the downstream task.
And this brings an important
question of whether
the computational
graph that is used for message
passing does necessarily,
be the same as
the input graph.
There are many
good reasons why
we'd like to
decouple the two,
one of which I
already mentioned,
the the bottleneck
phenomenon.
So you might rewire your graph
to make it more convenient.
And another reason is that,
the graph can actually be,
as I as I already said,
it can be done in a way that,
that is optimal for
some downstream
task. And sometimes the graph
that can be learned
in this way,
setting that we call latent
graph learning,
might be more important than
the downstream task itself so
it can provide
some interpretation
of the of the problem
or the classification
results. And we did with my
collaborators in Munich,
a recent work where we looked
at health care
electronic records of,
different patients.
And graph neural networks have
been applied to these
problems before,
but we can craft it graphs.
And here we show that learning
the graph as part
of the process by,
by graph neural
network provides
better results and also better
hopes to interpret
these results.
And, thinking maybe broader in
retrospective, this kind of
methods is related to what was
called manifold learning or
nonlinear dimensionality
reduction,
a class of approaches
that, modeled,
the data as sampled from some
low dimensional manifold that
lives in a high
dimensional space and,
tries tried them to represent
this dataset in
a lower dimensional
space by preserving
some structures
such as geodesic distance and
then applying,
machine learning
algorithms such as clustering
on the slow dimensional
representation.
So, the problem with these
approaches was
that the different
steps were
completely disconnected
from each other.
And you first had to to create
some
handcrafted representation
of the data, then
build the graph
that represents the structure
and only then apply
machine learning.
And sometimes it
required a lot
of tuning by hand of how you
represent the data
and build the graph.
Now with graph
learning pipelines,
you can, put all these stages
into a single end to end
differentiable pipeline,
and that's why I call these
methods meaningful
learning two dot o.
It brings all these
steps into a single,
architecture. And
probably we'll
see more
interesting applications
of these methods and one,
maybe a little
bit exotic field
where these, matters
are already,
been shown quite,
quite interesting to produce
quite cool results
is high energy
physics where you
can think of,
interactions of,
different particles.
And, one of the key
problems is
to reconstruct
the interaction graph.
So there are many,
open theoretical
questions about,
performance guarantees,
expressive power,
generalization,
robustness of
perturbations, and so on.
And, I think what
has been done
so far is just the tip
of the iceberg.
Last but not least,
and I apologize maybe running
a little bit over time,
I would like to
finish with a few
examples of what they
call killer apps.
So something like
computer vision,
was the killer app for,
for traditional deep learning
and conversational
neural networks.
For, graph neural
networks, we see,
we see them applied
to a lot of
different problems
since graphs
are really very abstract and
universal models
for systems of
relations and interactions.
You can find them in
particle physics,
in recommender systems, in,
problems in social
networks and
computational chemistry.
But, if you ask me what would
be one field of
which I am willing
to bet where these
methods would
probably make a breakthrough,
I would say these are problems
in medicine and biology,
and you can apply
graphs on all
scales from nano to macro,
from modeling molecules and
interactions between molecules
to entire patient networks.
And some of
the results here are
really extremely promising.
I would even say dramatic.
So one, on the nanoscale,
one application is that we can
model molecules as graphs and
predict their properties,
which is a holy grail of drug
design because the space in
which we operate is
humongously large.
We have something like ten to
the sixty of possibly
synthesizable,
small molecules.
Whereas, what we can test in
clinical environment is maybe
a few hundreds of compounds.
So we somehow
need to to bridge
this gap computationally.
And at the lower
level, we can do,
quantum mechanical models and
molecular dynamics and maybe
some approximations
such as DFT.
So, craft neural networks,
already several years ago were
shown by any work
by by DeepMind
by Justin Gilmer to be,
at the level of
DFT while being
several orders of
magnitude faster.
And this is really a cheap
alternative to,
more complex
quantum mechanical
simulations for predicting
properties of potential
drug candidates.
And one doubt that you always
have when you
work on this kind
of biological or
chemical problems
that it is too simplified and
kind of spherical
course in a vacuum
from the famous joke, but,
probably not
anymore and GraphML
is already on the radar of
pharmaceutical companies.
And earlier this year,
the group of colleagues at MIT
showed the discovery of a new
class of antibiotics
where graph
neural networks were used in
the virtual
screening pipeline.
So in our application also,
in drug design,
drugs are typically
small molecules,
but their targets are usually
large molecules, proteins.
And, proteins are
among the most
important, molecules
in our body.
They play crucial
role in almost
every biological process.
And, in some targets, unlike,
what we see with
small molecules,
they're considered to be very
difficult target by small
molecules because
they have flat
interfaces. So they're,
what is called undruggable.
And, it is possible to develop
a new class of drugs called
biologics or biological drugs
where the drug molecule itself
is a protein. And it allows to
address these
kind of targets.
And with my
colleagues at EPFL,
we've used geometric
deep learning
to predict protein binding
properties and then construct
new proteins from scratch for
this called de novo
protein design.
And we showed, for example,
that we can design
proteins that
disrupt the programmed death
ligand complex that is used as
target for, cancer
immunotherapy.
And, this approach potentially
could pave the way to a new
generation of
biological anticancer
therapies. So this was a paper
that appeared on the cover of
Nature Methods,
in the February
issue this year.
And at the high level
of abstraction,
we can use graphs to
model the interactions
between molecules
such as proteins
and drugs as
the the protein to
protein interaction drug.
And, in if you think of,
the drug traditional
drug therapy,
in many cases, we see multiple
drugs that are administered at
the same time.
Medics call this
polypharmacy or
combinatorial therapy,
and it comes with
the risks that
some interactions of the drugs
can produce bad,
or even potentially
dangerous effects.
And, it is impossible
to clinically
test all the,
millions of
possible combinations
between all the FDA
approved drugs,
and graph neural networks were
shown to be successful in
predicting drug
side effects or
drug interactions.
So the interactions are not
necessarily bad.
They can actually
be synergistic.
And, I'm part of the the cover
coalition that,
tries to to develop
graph models
for predicting
synergistic effects of,
combinatorial
treatments against
COVID nineteen.
So I will finish with the last
example that takes
ideas of drug
requisitioning to
the domain of food.
And itself drugs,
we can look at drug
like molecules
that are contained in food and
you you know that many plant
based foods belong to
the same class of,
chemicals that are
used as as drugs.
So it's not surprising that,
for example, many,
anti cancer therapies
are actually,
synthetic analogs of molecules
that you can find in plants.
And we're reading
just thousands or,
of such molecules,
polyphenols,
flavonoids,
terpenoids, indoles.
I'm pretty sure
that most of you
have never heard of them.
In fact, they
still remain large
and unexplored by experts.
They are never
tracked by any,
any regulatory bodies.
So this is truly
the dark matter
of nutrition. And,
with collaborations
at Imperial College,
we used graph based,
ML techniques to discover drug
like molecules in
food and then,
identify which foods,
would work the best
and hope to
prevent or or treat diseases.
This is really the first way
this somewhat
simplistic attempt
to use graph neural
networks for
this problem of
predicting health
effects of biologically active
molecules in full by modeling
their network effect.
And, in a longer perspective,
our ambition is to
provide quantum
leap in how we,
prescribe, design,
and prepare our food.
And as a conceptual
take on this,
we partnered with
the molecular
chef who used the ingredients
we have identified
to prepare simple,
tasty, and, and cheap recipes
that you can actually
find online.
So I think it's a good moment
to end on this
tasty note and,
well, probably we need to come
back and see what whatever I
have prognosticated here,
how much of this
has materialized,
in the next, few years.
So thank you very much.